heute zeigt jetzt macht ist moniert
einfach alle marken also herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video heute
machen wir ihrem kind gelesen eine blind
tasting blickt geschmack erkennen oder
auch nicht
da wollen wir gerade eben bleibt ob ich
habe die richtige gemacht nicht gesehen
hat und was die welt gegenwärtig
nacheinander zu probieren jemand zwar
hat der andere jeweils getrennt waffe
gekauft
dazu haben wir selbst der youtuber ein
profiteam eclipse mit dem mann in die
augen blind werden und sagen mein
natürlicher vorgang abhängig machen
glaube ganz guter abend waren von mir
klar jetzt kommt ein kursschiff sich in
einer woche kommt das fasten
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
jetzt probiert werden ist keine schande
der titel von der marke doc berufen nein
glaube ich schon einmal hier schon
einmal das tun kann ok harmonieren
normale sachen geholt oder bestimmte
leute ihr weg direkt besitzt und die
sachliche gehabt aber ich hab einfach
keine affäre geht es nach dem was das
ist immer der trainer muss überlegen was
kann seine karriere braucht muss immer
sonntags verpackt was man nicht ohne
weiteres ausbreiten kann
[Musik]
gummi verständigen
[Applaus]
das genaue zahl umfasse das war früher
bei auszusetzen wollten habe ich auch
noch etliches material arbeitet mit red
bull
deutsch schreiben die kommentare im
kraftraum pflegen des rektorats leute
haben wir einen markt noch ganz
klassisch daran auch nur ein jeden fall
ist zwar ist internet nicht so
einzigartig macht einen reifen da hätten
wir die nächste sache
das ist meine basis zu wissen denn
[Musik]
[Applaus]
geschmeckt
[Musik]
an der spitze steht 2 2
weil ich so kalt dass ich dachte wie
netzteil von irgendeinem film in münchen
auch gegen die hessen taten sich schwer
zu erraten oder technisch durchs werk
erlebten muss man den zunge rausstrecken
mit den einheiten und ich falle dann
drauf bin über meinen schmerz erklärt
minimalgewicht vorschlag gibt es 600
[Musik]
backpulver national wird immer noch die
wichtigste partie agierten
[Musik]
warum stoppt die welt wieder soweit ich
die finger einfach noch ein bisschen von
der nase weg nehmen willst und sowas und
[Applaus]
eine idee was ich mache
kleine klassen fuhren wird man sagt dann
immer gefährdet wenn ich nicht mehr
kleine alexandra nicht so gut da nimmst
du die finger und hätte als unter dem
reiter richtig der folge ruch des todes
kameras nicht übertragen können
nachdem hakan keser nach kresse nach
backpulver ein bisschen allem aktiv
keiner klebt nach für menschen hoffen
dass viele menschen auch anderen verein
gegangen er hatte überlegt
da werden wir genau abrechnen können als
zustandsbeschreibung
[Musik]
[Applaus]
dank dieser weise schaden weil hier das
video hier und hier oben gibt